hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissin and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today
is a comedian freddie quinn welcome to
trigonometry hi
thanks for having me i am a fascinating
person
good
we can tell uh you don't even know which
camera to look at the level of
professionalism among comedians is
very well known uh but listen it's good
to have you here actually for
most people won't know this obviously
because they don't have access to my
facebook messenger
uh thankfully uh you and i were having a
conversation
in the wake of this thing that happened
on frankie boyle's new world order
yeah where a comedian made the joke
or trying to explain that when blm
supporters say
kill whitey they don't really mean kill
whitey and the joke was
we do right right and
i sort of said that i always defend the
comedian's right
to make a joke but i also thought it was
inappropriate for whoever produced that
show to include that bit i thought it
was ill-judged
uh at which point a lot of people sort
of had some pushback on it
and uh he's scratching his ear and you
were one of them but i actually thought
the way you and i talked about it was
pretty sensible
um so because you disagree we thought
we'd get you on and we'll have a chat
about it
yeah man i look i think disagree with
people
is a good thing like i never get those
people
that like have big facebook statuses and
if if you disagree on this
unfriend me now and it's like why would
you want to surround yourself by
people that think exactly the same as
you do i like that we think different
things man and i like that we can talk
about it
so i mean the fact that obviously i'm
right as well you know makes me feel a
lot better
well so to tell everybody what your take
on the whole situation was
so right i was a little bit the reason
that i messaged you
is because i was a little bit surprised
that you
um sort of were kind of
against that because that's what it was
really you were against
it being heard weren't you the kill
whitey thing yeah
i was against it being broadcast on the
principle that i thought you probably
wasn't the best part of that show i mean
maybe the tragedy is that it was but um
i don't know my point is i thought it
was an ill-advised thing for the bbc to
broadcast
uh that's not to say that she should be
censored or punished for the joke
yeah but we all know we try new material
for example we don't include
stuff that doesn't work very well do we
so that was my thought on it
but it is to say that what you're doing
is you're passing the issue of
censorship
from the comic to the editor which i
don't think is
a way of dealing with the issue i think
you want to remove that censorship
altogether that's surely everyone's end
goal isn't it
like i don't understand why you would
say oh well the comic can say oh it's
fine for the comic to say it
but the editor then has to make the
choice blame the editor i just feel like
it was passing the book
um well my my take on it is that
you when you create curate a program you
don't include
everything you make choices editorial
choices about what you include
and i thought particularly at that
moment in time where the racial
conversation was very heated
that was a very ill-advised thing to
broadcast it doesn't mean as i say that
the comedian should be punished or
censored or anything like that
i just didn't think it was a good bit of
of thing to include that's all
so why was it why was it ill-advised
uh because i thought it wasn't funny
number one okay i agree on that
let's stop i agree with you that i mean
i don't personally think it was funny
but two things number one i'm not the
target audience
for race related comedy do you know what
i mean so
aren't you i'm not i'm not i'm not the
barometer look i'm not
i don't you know the bits that i've seen
of sophie's
stand up i don't find it particularly
funny but i
i'm not the target audience for it so
i'm not like
i'm not weirdly naive enough to think
that everything in the world should be
tailored to suit me
it's not to my taste but give a [ __ ]
uh it's it's not important that it
wasn't funny um
it's just meaningless it doesn't matter
whether or not it's funny or not
it was obviously intended as a joke like
like of it that's indisputable like
there's no i don't know about that
there's a lot of people who would
dispute that
yeah but those people aren't on rational
thinking but
surely not because i mean here's how you
can tell it was a joke right
she said we don't want to kill whitey
and then she literally does an aside she
turns her body
and goes we do and then she goes we
don't we don't we don't
she literally moves her body in order to
sell that joke
and she she's being booked as a comedian
on a comedy related show
it's just her way of solidifying the
reason that she is to be there and i
felt it was ad-libbed as well i didn't
feel like it was
premeditated or anything like that so
for me it was a massive storm in a tea
cup
and i i think that the uk is very
uncomfortable
with um seeing issues about race
on tv i mean i mean look at the
britain's got talent thing the other day
of
uh nabil abdul rasheed uh did
his set on britain's got talent
semi-final and got 730 odd complaints
yeah i think that's definitely there's a
lot of snowflakery on both sides but
um the issue on that particular thing
and i'm aware that francis hasn't said
anything for
the first 10 minutes of the show which
means it'll be a great episode yeah
absolutely uh but
uh the the thing with that one is i mean
she is trying to defend
a phrase that is literally about
inflicting violence on people right
using humor right kill whitey i mean
killing
white people is a phrase that's about
that right so
let's say uh leo curse the only
right-wing comedian who
who might be tempted to say something
like that went on that same program and
when
when we talk about putting black people
back into slavery
we don't mean it i mean we do right and
he turned his body in the same way and
he did the same thing
do you think the response would have
been the same as it was to this
particular incident
well obviously not but
i i i see that more as a
lack of consistency on both sides to be
i don't really think it's the it's
really the same issue to be honest with
you
i mean this whole like you can say this
so why can't we say that there's never
an exact parallel do you know what i
mean
like what you've done is you've kind of
created a scenario that hasn't existed
and asked me to compare it and i don't
really
like i don't get look here's the thing i
can understand
why people would find it offensive
but my line is about consistency if you
think it's offensive
fine good for you you think it's
offensive
then that's fine but you have to think
that everything's offensive and treat it
the same way
you can't for example kick off
about sophie juker saying kill whitey
but at the same time
think that the count dankula pug thing
was absolutely fine
because to me there's an underlying
thing there about
censorship and freedom of speech that
should be consistent throughout and the
same
goes for the other way as well you can't
be lambasting count dankula and going
how do we do this blah blah blah
but at the same time go oh no sophie's
fine
for me consistency is what we should be
aiming for
francis why didn't you say something and
one thing that i wanted to ask you
freddie is do you think comedy is being
used more and more as a political
football by
both sides of the spectrum so you have
the left when it comes to count dankula
uh and the jokes that they he that he
made
and saying you know this is
anti-semitism etc etc
we saw with joe brand when she made the
battery acid comment
you had people like farage on the right
say that what she said was unacceptable
do you think that more and more comedy
is being used as a football by both
sides to try and prove a point
i think it's a really easy way of
point scoring isn't it it's a really
easy way
of um creating segregation between
them and us do you know what i mean it's
it
to me it's two sides of the same coin
yeah i find it ridiculous but when
people only choose to
to back the things that ally with their
courts
do you know what i mean like i'm for
like really largely for freedom of
speech within comedy i mean i think that
if you're on stage as a comedian then
you should really be allowed to say
um you know whatever you want within
reason providing it's
absolutely a joke and you know it's
it is um sort of
concurrent with you know society and
stuff like that
i mean i'm not saying that you should be
able to go on stage and
talk about race like it's the 70s or
anything like that you know i mean it
has to be concurrent with you know where
societies are
but i mean i just find it daft
maybe you're right francis maybe it is
political point scoring
i just think it's people being fickle to
be honest with you
i think that it's it's way easier for
you to take something
and try and amalgamate it with your
political beliefs
than it is to try and be underlyingly
consistent
about a particular issue and do you
think there is a problem with freedom
and speech in comedy freddie
do you think that comedians are being
censored or do you think this is just uh
right-wing comedians throwing their
hands up in the air and moaning about
nothing
well that's i mean i find it irritating
that the issue of freedom of speech
within comedy
goes hand in hand with being right wing
do you know what i mean like yeah very
much so mate
i i find it very annoying because i
wouldn't classify myself as
right wing at all uh and to me
personally um you know having
values like freedom of speech and stuff
has always been a typically left-wing
thing for me
you know like letting people express
themselves freely i
i think it's quite a liberal thing isn't
it so
for me for it to be associated with with
right wing
you know ideology and stuff i i just
don't understand where that's come from
um now well you get put in that box the
moment you say anything about free
speech neither francis or i are right
wing but both of us are
regularly thought of as that in in the
comedy world at least now which i had
the bank balance to be right-wing
yeah you die and as long as i'm in
control of the finances of this show
nor will you insert anti-semitic joke
exactly
uh maybe you are right-wing after all
but uh but
but the point is that the moment you
start talking about free speech everyone
immediately says that you are right wing
in comedy and then you
sort of like that's that's just how it
is but i guess what francis was getting
up and i think this is a
much broader much of a broader issue
that's more interesting perhaps to talk
about is
do you actually think there's a problem
with you know hypersensitivity do you
think there's a problem with people
being
uh sensorious in comedy taking offense
too easily
etc yeah absolutely uh
if you speak to the majority of
working club comics they'll tell you
that people get offended
way too easily um do you know what it's
down to i think
honestly i think the reason that people
have become
so easily offended is
the culture of social media like
the way that everyone's got a instagram
account and a twitter
account and so people are used to
feeling like their opinions
should be heard all of the time so
if somebody sees a piece of stand up and
they
don't like it or they're offended by it
it used to be
back in the day 10 years ago if you if
you can believe this
if somebody didn't like a piece of stand
up then they'd just ignore it
and wait for the next joke i mean it was
a crazy system and i don't know how we
managed
um but now with with the way that social
media is
everybody feels as though the opinions
need to be heard and felt
all the time and so yeah i think there
is a problem
with uh with people becoming too easily
offended um
and i think it's it's it's not as easy
as um it's not as easy as saying
like a blanket statement people are too
easily offended
i think uh it's more nuanced than that
and i think it comes down to
people not readily wanting to
hear certain voices
saying certain things so what i mean by
that
is that i feel as a offensive
um northern working class comic
um i am afforded less maneuverability
than some of my
middle class well-educated counterparts
so if i say something offensive then i'm
horrific and offensive and horrible
whereas you know if a
middle-class white gentleman you know
said something then they are
genre defying and challenging and
boundary pushing
do you know what i mean yeah but don't
you think that also
speaks to the classism within our
society and also
the classism within comedy critics as
well
oh there's this huge classism within
society
uh and within comedy uh absolutely
enormous i mean
if you look at the uh the edible fringe
which is still for some reason the
biggest
deal amongst comedians like that
couldn't be any more skewed
towards people with money to spend do
you know what i mean
and even if you can afford it uh you
know when i
took my show up last year i i had a paid
venue
and i sold 93 of my tickets
and if it hadn't been for the fact that
i stayed with friends for the whole
month
i would have lost money oh it's crazy
there's a there's a
very famous story of
um the comedian chris ramsey having a
breakout year with
uh with an edinburgh show and i think he
sold out every
run or something like that um you know
he sold out every night of his run
he got nominated for an edinburgh award
and he still lost like four grand
or something like that freddie let's
just come back to the bigger picture
because i feel like
this is very interesting to the three of
us and seven open mic comedians who may
be watching
but uh the audience more broadly
probably couldn't give a [ __ ]
francis did you know that investing is
one of the best ways to preserve your
wealth over the long term
what's wealth something you will never
find out as long as i have control of
the trigonometry account
however if you do have wealth high
commission and clunky products
from traditional stock brokers make it
very difficult for people like me
to start investing good for everyone
else though
free trade has come up with an
award-winning app that is currently
being used by over 250
000 people it's fca approved and fscs
protected it's brilliant it allows you
to trade commission free
free trade has won best online trading
platform at the british bank awards
two years in a row 2019 and 2020.
they offer no speculative products no
spread betting no day trading
it's all about preserving and growing
your wealth over long term
no hidden fees transparent price and
structure very simple to use
you can sign up for a general investment
account or a stocks and shares
isa or sign up to free trade plus for
more advanced order types and a bigger
stock universe
they've also got other new products
coming soon you can get a universe
go to free trade dot io slash trigger
register and fund your account
and you'll get a randomly allocated free
share
worth between three and two hundred
pounds could be in a great company like
right move apple even greg's great so
when you invest your capital is at risk
the value of your investments can go up
as well as down and you may receive back
less than you originally invested you
knew that bit off by heart
uh let's come back to the other point
you made which i think is a very very
good
one which is that how you are perceived
in terms of material that you do in
other words the words that you say
depends largely on how you are perceived
as a person so
a big northern working-class bloke like
you
sounds like if you're doing material
accord that's offensive
there's is it that people are much more
readily assuming that you mean
the offensive stuff you say as a joke or
that they just
they recoil and horrid the thought of
someone who looks like a viking saying
it
um do you know what i think it is i
think there's a hangover
of uh northern working-class comedians
from the 70s
you know you you bernard mannings and
such
uh and your chubby browns and that sort
of thing and i hear us on this show
sorry heroes on this show obviously
but i think that if you like um you know
if you if
if you're a northern working class and
you you know you sound
a bit rough around the edges and you
know uneducated
then i think people automatically put
you in that bracket
before you've even started your joke
and once people have that frame of mind
oh this is going to be
controversial this is going to be
unacceptable then
they can contextualize everything
through that lens
and it becomes very diffic like
difficult to extrapolate comedy out of
that
because people are they're not looking
for the humor anymore they're looking
for the offense
and also don't you think as well that
when you're perceived the way you're
perceived by the industry in particular
comedy critics they perceive you in a
certain way you always see the
references
northern northern working class comic
etc etc
and again they view you through that
particular lens it's almost like you're
a cookie cutter
of another type of northern cla northern
working class comedian
yeah it's it's shorthand for them isn't
it because
the standard of reviewers um is
is not very good you know i mean like
it's very rare that you get an objective
uh review of a comedy performance and uh
another irk of mine is that i tend to
find that reviewers are
way too um ready to
sort of inject their own tastes into the
so for me personally a review should be
what is this person doing and how well
are they doing it
that should be it like you don't see
mark commode
you know doing uh a film review
about a rom-com and going oh well you
know the script was fantastic and the
two characters had real chemistry
and the film was well paced and full of
surprises and it was shot in a way that
was interested and unique
but i just don't like romantic comedies
two stars do you know
no it's you know it is it is a very very
good point
and but looking at tv as well i think
the
way you see the real bias in comedy is
where we talk about
diversity and you know we must have
diversity
and you see all these people and lots of
different colors and there's
more women now which obviously is a
great thing but they all seem to have
gone to oxford in private school
yeah i am for diversity
but i think what we should be focusing
on
is diversity of voices not diversity of
faces
which is where i think the problem lies
for me
personally a um
20 year old uh
white lad from oxford
and a 60 year old white man from
cumbria are going to have vastly
different
you know life stories and experiences
and i think it's um i think it's really
strange
how we just assume that because they're
both
white and male they're going to be
speaking about the same things
do you know what i mean like if you look
at i mean there's huge
strides in in diversity and comedy at
the moment
and you know it's fine but if you look
at
well look i mean it's fine do you know
what i mean like
good you know i i don't really have
anything to
to say it doesn't really affect me to be
honest with you because
doesn't it freddie well the way look the
way that i see it
is like 15 years ago
white northern working-class man was
currency do you know what i mean like
you look at you peter k
dave spikey paddy mcginner you know i
mean
it was it was a golden generation to be
a white man from the north west
uh and nowadays you know we can't get a
look in
whatever do you know what i mean is it's
it'll be cyclical
in in 10 years time you know it'll
change again
it's all cyclical list you know it's
it's just a phase i
i mean i think it's i think it's good
particularly
that there's more um you know
female acts and people of color and
things like that i think that's
important because
like i i do buy into the idea
that if all you see is straight white
men doing stand up then that's just
going to encourage more straight white
men to do stand up
like there has to be a point where you
show
all the people in there and then the
next generation
you know we're going to look at that and
go oh i can do that because
somebody else is on tv that looks like
me is doing it and you know that will
in the long term you know um lead for
you know a depth of quality um you know
across
you know the whole circuit i think
that's a largely good thing
but when you're talking about diversity
at the moment um
there's two fields that are massively
being neglected
and that is a class and age
so and why do you think it's it's
important
that class is represented why do i think
it's important that class is represented
do you know it is true isn't it that
everybody
sees the lack of representation in the
thing that they identify with
do you know what i mean like well this
is where i don't agree a little bit
freddie because
it never occurred to me that i need to
see a russian jewish immigrant
doing comedy for me to do it that that
was not enough
one's enough exactly that never occurred
to me uh i
i don't need to see a russian jewish
comedian
doing uh a youtube show talking about
political and cultural issues it never
occurred to me that that's
that i need that do you know so i i
don't really
i think we've bought into the site
narrative which i don't personally agree
with
i know loads of people who've done
something being the first person to do
it
uh i'm not sure that and particularly
this was the other question i was going
to ask you and it's a bit of a pointed
one so feel free to
to dodge it do you not feel the
part of the drive and i say this as
someone who really doesn't have a dog in
the fight anymore
uh i'm done with club comedy i'll do my
own shows to my own audience i'm really
not
i'm not rooting for me to get any
opportunities at all i really genuinely
don't have a dog in the fight
but as a neutral observer watching it do
you not think that the drive for
diversity has meant
that there's been a drop in quality
right okay let's let's go for the first
question
first and then because there's two big
old issues there francis
and uh okay cool i'm not getting
involved mate you crack on freddie
constancy sorry so look right
um first of all what i would say is that
you have
really drilled down into your own
identity
uh and you've drilled down right into
the specific russian jew
uh and it's like yeah there ain't no
other rush jews
you know fine whatever but if you look
at it on the broad
umbrella term of white bloke there's
[ __ ] loads of us
you know i mean and we're and we're all
over the place
and we're all on tv and we're all you
know
historically we've all been in stand up
in that
and so if if you look at it in terms of
just white man
there's loads of other people like you
in that sense
doing the things that you do i i get
what you're saying
about somebody has to be the first and
that's
true but i do buy into the fact
look like maybe i
would have been a great ballet dancer
maybe i would have properly made it but
it's
just an interesting example there yeah
but but in my head
you know ballet dancing is really like a
female thing
like i know that women do it and things
like that but because actually i know
that men do it but because i've
predominantly seen women do it
i never even thought about it growing up
it wasn't even
you know it wasn't even something that i
mean they made a film about that didn't
they freddie
oh my god but yeah i mean look it's
i i think that if you have really good
um you know diverse acts on tv
um i i don't think it's a stretch
to say that there are gonna be you know
young women
watching uh stand-up comedy shows who
are really big comedy fans
who watch and they see uh ashlyn b
or rasheen connerty or fern brady
or you know catherine ryan and they
watch these amazing acts and they go
oh my god i could be like them do you
know what i mean it's like a role model
thing man
do you have a business do you want to
make the most of your business do you
want to advertise online
but don't know where to do it well how
about you advertise with trigonometry we
have
over 200 000 subscribers across the
different platforms
we sometimes get up to three million
views a month for our videos
and it's a great opportunity to showcase
your product so if you want your product
or business to stand out
amidst all the nonsense that is
happening drop
us a line at marketing trigger pod dot
co
dot uk that's marketing at trigger pod
dot co dot uk and we will do our very
best
to help your product stand out and when
we say stand out what we really mean is
get cancelled
all right so so the other question was
are they seeing the grey act
or is the push for diversity lowering
the quality
uh on tv or in clubs
uh well let's start with tv i think
that's what we were talking about
originally
okay so um on on
tv um i would
say that quality is being lowered uh
because people are focusing on diversity
and i don't think that that's uh i i
know that there will be people watching
that and going oh
you can't say that but really i mean
it's
not interesting i think i i honestly
think it's a crying shame
that there are acts like jeff innocent
and mick ferry and curry marks
and adam bloom who are incredible
uh acts that get next to no television
uh and there are other acts who are on
um you know comedy shows that
get you know that they're basically
you know open spots promising open spots
and they're getting
tv um i think that is the point where
we've kind of jumped the shark a little
bit
um and you know what it's it's it's
funny really
because when i think about this i i'm
not
like i'm not trying to be bitter about
it
because quite frankly if you
are early on in your career and somebody
gives you
the opportunity to go on
you know itv one prime time and do
three minutes of comedy or whatever then
that's a brilliant opportunity and you
should
absolutely take it do you know what i
mean uh oh
of course it's never about the acts
themselves you can't
ever blame people for uh who've been
given an opportunity for taking it
and if you were in in their place and
suddenly we had a massive quota for
bearded northern blokes
no one would no one would blame you for
jumping on that
uh i just love to watch all the northern
blokes suddenly grow beards
yeah well they already have i think but
um but what what i think we are talking
about here is
the system more broadly aren't we yeah
it's look i mean there's there's a drive
for that
it goes back to what i was saying before
about it being cyclical there's a drive
for diversity at the moment
so if you know if you're a a diverse
site you're going to get those
opportunities
more early on in your career than you
know
perhaps what you should do that's true
it's not it's not anyone's fa
i think if anything it's the um
it's it's it's down to you know the
major
tv networks and how they choose to
to show comedy and um you know it's
it's it it does lead to i mean let's be
fair
the question that you asked was does it
lead to a depth
in uh you know has it led to a depth
in uh quality and
i don't think it is um i don't think
anyone would disagree with the statement
that it is not the best acts that end up
on television
certainly not always but that's the same
with with most industries like
the best musicians don't end up on you
know top of the pops or
whatever it is you know like it's just
the way that it is
and freddie you were talking about you
know seeing you know white men on
television
and you know people who look like you
and i'll put the question to you isn't
that quite a new way of looking at it
because when i was a kid right and i'm
actually someone from a mixed race
background and i looked at
like someone on tv the first thing i
would look at would be for a prism of
class i've just got all their posh all
that
i would look at these people on screen
and think i couldn't do that
because they come from a posh background
yeah
i i but it's it's the same thing as um
as what i was saying you know what i
mean you you know you look for people
that are like you on telly and you go
well i can do that too
it doesn't matter if they look like you
or sound like you it's all the same deal
yeah but you would argue as well that
working class people in particular
aren't getting represented in comedy so
this way of saying well
this person is a white man therefore you
know i i make a connection with him
i i don't think it works like that
because i think we're so
classy in this country that if someone's
a white bloke but very very posh
on screen i don't see a connection with
him
your classist is what you're saying yeah
right okay well
i i you're framing it in a way that
makes it sound like we disagree whereas
i think that we we agree here
yeah i think you do i think you do but
freddie so
let's come back a little bit to what you
were saying earlier which is where i
think
we come right back to the beginning
about the bbc putting out
that uh joke that that neither of us i
think thinks is funny
and and this is the part that a lot of
comedians are missing
which is the bbc is
at great risk at the moment because
there's a lot of people who feel
simultaneously that
it doesn't like them that a lot of the
content that's being put out by the bbc
is biased against them
and at the same time they feel that it
doesn't necessarily represent their
views
and a lot of people certainly a lot of
people that we hear from also feel that
the comedy output on the bbc
has dropped in quality now whether
that's to do with diversity or not is a
different issue maybe
uh because of the different technologies
that we have now netflix amazon prime
whatever
everyone can watch exactly what they
want and therefore something that
that appeals to everyone no longer
exists i don't know but
certainly the bbc is the thread there's
a big campaign to defund the bbc
and that was also part of my thought
process when i was critical
of them putting that bit out i just
thought in an environment where the bbc
is already on the threat under threat of
being defunded
pushing those quite divisive uh ideas
under the pretense of comedy wasn't
necessarily a good outcome for the bbc
and i'm a big fan of the bbc right okay
so what i would say to that is that the
definition of
comedy is not what you personally find
funny
so because you don't find it funny it
doesn't mean that it's not under the
pretense of comedy she was
clearly joking like it's it's to me it's
a clear
joke now whether or not it's funny like
i say completely
completely irrelevant um
i mean i think that you you tying in two
separate issues to be honest with you
i don't think that anyone's gonna
specifically
like like you know be be all of a sudden
you know passionate about defunding the
bbc because
someone's heard a joke that they don't
like and no you're very wrong about that
you're very wrong about that freddie i
i'm happy to disagree and genuinely i
really
appreciate that we're having this
conversation but on that issue i can
just tell you
from people that i hear from that that
is not correct
there are a lot of people do those
people then
are they not so flippant that they will
change their
minds once the next issue comes up no no
it's more to them it's more of a straw
that broke the camel's back
issue it's like they feel that the bbc
wasn't particularly interested in their
views
it maybe they voted leaving the
referendum
and they feel that the bbc after the
referendum was quite
uh keen to make out or leave voter sound
like bigoted racist etc
it doesn't really represent them anymore
and now you've got a comedian
talking about killing whitey and joking
that that's the intention of the whole
slogan
uh and it's sort of like the straw that
breaks the camel's back
um and i and look i'm not trying to win
this argument by any stretch of the
imagination no i think it's
interesting i'm just putting that
information to you that there are a lot
of people that i hear from that very
much feel that way
but why would they have been watching
that show then
like i i i don't get what
how many of those people do you reckon
we're actually watching that show
zero yeah and and so it and we're
offended i think
the majority of these people see a tiny
little snippet
because the whole thing was about a
discussion about
you know racing society and stuff like
that and so
yeah i mean my but my issue is if you
don't like it
don't engage with it don't watch it
because if you do that
it goes away it's a [ __ ] great system
i this is the same thing that i i talk
about and it broadly talks about
what we're talking about with offense in
comedy like if i'm doing a set
and i am quite an offensive act if i say
something
that offends you um then there's a great
thing that you can do you don't have to
put your hand up you don't have to shout
out
you don't have to tell me how offended
you were what you
right here's what you do you don't make
a sound
and if enough people agree with you and
also don't make a sound
i don't do the joke because it isn't
funny
it's a perfect system i don't see why
i and i think it goes to a bigger point
that at the moment
people are so like
self-serving that there seems to be this
attitude nowadays that
everything made has to cater to me
everything has to be for me and i'm
i'm not putting any political bias on
that i think it happens at both sides of
the political spectrum
um you know it has to be for me
you know that joke about killing whitey
uh i can guarantee you
oh i can guarantee you i can't guarantee
you all i don't know why i just said
that
um i bet that if you were somebody who
grew up where ace was
you know a huge issue in your life
something you battled racism on a on a
daily basis
and it's something that you really had
to live with um
and something that you were really hyper
aware of you'd be watching that show
you know or you'd be more likely to
watch that show
you wouldn't be offended by what was
just said you'd
naturally you'd see it as a joke you
know i mean look sophie
played the audience that she anticipated
was gonna watch it
is it her fault that a load of people
saw an out of context clip
saw a one-minute segment of an hour-long
show and went how dare she
this isn't what i pay my license for i
think the attitude that needs to change
is within people
and do you know what i think part of the
problem is is that
there is an absolute death of comedians
with a different point of view
politically
on the bbc so immediately she says that
joke
on a overtly left-wing program and you
know it
it is from what i've seen a comedy slash
political show but they don't seem to
get anybody on
from the right side of the spectrum even
jeff norca can't get a sniff on there
yeah
and so people just see that as another
example of bbc bias
so who did they have on that show they
had uh sarah pascoe
they had um dane baptiste
and they are jamali maddox okay
who would you have had on there to
redress that balance
freddie what we're really talking about
is all of the people on that show agree
with each other
that's what we're talking about ah right
okay fair enough
well yeah do you know what if well it it
it depends what you want in that show
then doesn't it
actually frankie boyle who hosts the
show he's not woke what are you what
about
uh he is very much just
pay attention to his twitter mate i'm
paying attention to his stand up
his stand-up isn't woke did you see the
special that he put out during lockdown
i haven't seen the special but he is
work believe me
right okay his stand-up isn't woke
though yeah he stand up
his stand-up uh no which is one of the
interesting things about it
uh that he's someone who made a career
of being
uh very offensive breaking boundaries
etc
uh but actually his opinions now have
become increasingly woke and it's an
interesting thing it's a transformation
that we've also seen in america with
someone like jim jeffries
uh who who made a career out of doing
sort of
jokes that i would never ever do uh rape
jokes and whatever and then he's
lecturing everyone about how we must
respect women three years later
maybe maybe uh people's
jokes uh are not necessarily their
opinions
and i think that we make a huge mistake
every time we assume that because a
comedian's joking about something
it means that they are uh you know for
or against that particular thing and it
and
beneath the joke is a sincere opinion
do you know it's i know i know what you
mean but i'm not suggesting that that
that was the case with frankie or jim
i'm not saying that
frankie always had this opinion and now
he has a different opinion i'm just
saying
if you listen to what frankie says
seriously he is woke
really i try not to do twitter you see
slides
and that's probably a good thing for me
i worry
right with twitter because i think i
think there's look
if the if if there was an app that uh
allowed you to like like connect to your
brain
and every thought that you had just went
onto a platform and everyone could see
it
there's no [ __ ] way you download that
app because the amount
of times that i think messed up
inappropriate stuff that i don't want
anyone else thinking
and twitter to me is just one extension
of that because the
the more people tweet the more
people lose the filter of is this tweet
right should i do this
so i don't pay attention to i'll use it
occasionally
but i think it's a poison platform so i
don't usually go on it man
it's i'm just worried that if i ever
achieve a modicum of success and
uh northern balding bearded men are back
in fashion with the bbc
then some [ __ ] will go through my
twitter timeline and
find a tweet from 2010 and i'm cancelled
before i've even started
but joking aside that is a very very
real fear though isn't it
do you ever feel that within comedy and
your comedy career that there are
right opinions and wrong opinions and
that ultimately if you hold a wrong
opinion
on any particular subject that that
could prevent you from progressing
oh mate or a hundred percent a hundred
percent loads of people feel like that
i've um i've i've i've recently started
doing a bit
like i've only done it once and the the
basis behind it
is that we should sort of we should
learn
to treat comedy as like a buffet
like if you go to a buffet you don't
expect to like everything on the spread
that's not what a buffet is about but as
long as you get your little plate full
of stuff that you like then everything
else doesn't matter you just pick the
bits that you like and then you have a
nice lovely time
like i don't like quiche and so
when i go to a buffet i just don't eat
like i don't
[ __ ] i just ignore the quiche and
then that works out fine because there's
always somebody who really likes quiche
who goes oh my god there's all this and
then they get to have more of the stuff
that they like and i get to have more
than the stuff that i like
i don't walk up to the case and go i
find this quiche offensive and throw it
across the [ __ ] room
stick it in the bin but isn't the
problem that
the person who goes i find this quiche
offender offensive or i don't like this
quiche
and walks away is a tv producer or
somebody who can potentially help you up
the ladder
and enable you to be more successful
mate
i i i think that is still a problem
but it's nowhere near as much of a
problem as it was five years ago
the way that the way that social media
comics are smart man
like you guys are clever do you know
like you two i do
konstantin has realized you know to sort
of you know brand himself properly and
francis has realized that constantin
knows what he's doing today
exactly it's a clever system that you
guys have got working
um but look we've we've adapted and
at the moment there are many comedians
who are cultivating their own
online following do you know what i mean
in the and the fan base that's what i
mean that's why i'm trying to
you know up youtube channel and put more
stuff out on there and things and
hey look at look at the stuff that you
guys have got you got 150 000
subscribers
you've got 150 000 people that tune into
everything that you say that's like what
what other channels
have that sort of reach on tv what does
does bbc3
average 150 000 viewers for all the [ __ ]
puts out
and you get to meet you get to be the
masters of your own destiny
you're the stars of every show that you
put out you get to edit it
and cut it and choose it however you
want you know we've had nah man we have
a northerner to do that
but you get my point though yeah five
years ago
it was dead important to please exact tv
executives
and it still it still is important or
whatever but it's getting less and less
and less important every day
because more and more acts are tuning
into this fact they're going
hang about wait a minute why am i why am
i waiting to do
you know three minutes um at you know 10
o'clock at night on a major tv show
why don't i just buy a camera and plug
it into a computer
and i'll start i'll start making my own
fan base hey i
look look at what um look at what nigel
long
has done during lockdown uh you know
nigel unger's has got what nearly two
million
uh uh facebook that's like youtube
subscribers now
that's enough to tour off he's set for
life
christ knows how much money he's gonna
make through advertising on his clips
and stuff
he's he's not waiting around for for
people to go
all right okay we need like a an asian
guy on our next show so let's bring him
on
he's he's done his own thing and more
and more acts
are tuning into that every single day if
you
if you gave me a choice legitimately if
you gave me a choice
between being on next season's live at
the apollo
or having 50 000 uh youtube subscribers
i would take the youtube subscribers
every single
day and freddie do you think that the
tv companies because of this lowering of
quality which i think we
everybody pretty much agrees with have
sown the sea to their own destruction
and that people turn on and they don't
they're not as invested in the whole
diversity agenda as
any as any of the rest of us or whatever
else look at it and go
oh that's not as funny as as you know as
a comedy used to be
switch off i'm gonna go on youtube look
it's
it's part of a rich tapas street you
know i mean
like maybe maybe it is part of what's
going on
but there's some there's plenty of
fantastic
diverse acts that for whatever reason
don't seem to get a look in like for
example
um when i was in london we were talking
before this about top secret comedy club
which is one of my favorite comedy clubs
in the country there's two acts that do
that regularly uh
tania moore and nico yearwood they're
both
bloody amazing comedians yeah both
friends of us yeah
and there's others as well this is
something that francis and i talk about
all the time there's plenty of other
black ethnic minority female acts who
don't get a look and and
again if you if you pay attention
there's reasons for that as well
which i certainly would say have
something to do with
with the with the sort of progressive
agenda but that's my
my take on it i i mean i watched um
you know last time i was uh top secret i
watched nico yeah would
blow the roof
off that gig he absolutely
annihilated it and i i find it
incredible that you know he's not being
given tv opportunities
i'd so for me it's it's not as simple as
to go
oh diver you know diversity is the issue
because it
it it's um it makes it sound
as though every female and every you
know person of color or whatever
is is being given the opportunities
and people are when actuality i think
there's loads of people who are great
the
for whatever reason aren't getting a
look in maybe look maybe it is
part of the reason as to why the bbc is
struggling at the moment but i think a
much much bigger reason is the fact that
youtube is miles better netflix is miles
better
do you know i mean like like how can the
bbc
um compete with youtube where you can
subs
you can physically find the stuff that
you like you can subscribe to it
and you can watch it whenever you like
it's
just you know the bbc hasn't even caught
up to that [ __ ] yet this whole on-demand
thing has been around for
years and then miles behind so
i think that's a bigger reason do you
think we should defund the bbc
freddie oh mate totally absolutely
between me and you i have not paid my
license in some time and that's
interesting
i didn't expect you to say that freddie
that was almost a tongue-in-cheek
comment why do you think we should
defund the bieb
what genuinely why do i think that we
should default yeah yeah yeah
because i resent i resent been forced to
pay for something that i have no control
over you know what goes on do you know
what i mean
like look right here's the thing is
i think that the way netflix works is
pretty [ __ ] good
because i subscribe i get loads of great
shows
and if they stop making great shows then
i unsubscribe
and that's and that's it and so what
netflix does
is they go oh well a lot of people have
watched this and really enjoyed this
i guess we better make more things like
this and
that that that works as a as a great
barometer of quality
whereas is it standing if you hold
people to ransom and
force them to pay 120 quid a year then
you know it's it's the quality of stuff
that's on the bbc
is nowhere near the quality that's on
these streaming platforms
so well it's interesting we're sort of
agreeing you're agreeing with a lot of
the stuff that i was saying and actually
maybe one of the reasons that
you know what i talked about the
breaking of the the camel's back thing
one of the reasons it's a bit different
with the bbc is that people are forced
to pay for it
so it's the combination of being forced
to pay for something
and then having stuff uh churned out
that you don't agree with or don't like
which pisses people off but it doesn't
matter i think you made your point very
clear on that
but in the same in the same vein though
like i'll tell you what i tell you what
pisses me off is
uh antiques roadshow like i i think it's
bollocks
but i'm not i'm not offended that it's
on do you know i mean like
no your point your point's well taken me
i i yeah i think you made your point
very clear
uh and i actually i think the important
point that you made about the takeover
of technology and the fact that
we all have our own destinies in our
hands now
so this whole oh this comedian got
promoted this is why i said to you i've
got no dog in this fight now because
i'm very happy with what we're doing
we've got this show
uh we've got our other stuff that we do
and i'm not really bothered about it
because if you
embrace the the power of the internet
and the technology
that's now available you can make a
success of your career you don't need
anyone to give you any opportunities
oh i mean for me for me personally i i
have started to pay so little attention
as to which comedians get booked onto
what
new stand-up shows i i i i i don't give
a [ __ ]
do you know what i mean like a look at
who's who's booked on this season's
stand-up sketch show i couldn't give a
[ __ ] because
it's just not something that i care
about um to be honest with you
the the thing that i care about is
performing comedy live
that's that's all's i'm asked about and
for me if i was ever
on television then the only reason that
i'd want to be on there
is so that i could get more fans so that
i could perform comedy live
more do you know what i mean and it's
easier for me
uh and way more convenient for me to try
and build my own
youtube channel or to try and build my
own social media following
than it is for me to try and pander to
tv executives
that don't even want what i'm selling
it's a good life comedy is doing well at
the moment
depends how good you are mate i've not
stopped gigging
boom comedian destroys former comedian
that's what we'll put
there this title as uh freddie thanks
very much for coming on we're running
out of time mate so we've got just one
more question for you which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
uh so there is a show on netflix
called uh american pit master bbq
and it's like great british bake off but
with like
barbecue slow roasts and stuff mate
nobody's watched it and i'm the only
[ __ ] guy that has it's it's
unbelievable and you know what there
just isn't enough
working-class northern men on that show
you know you know what i like about that
that was entirely
on brand on both of those answers
i'd love to be a pit master but i look
and they're all american and so i just
it's a dream that'll never finalize
itself for me mate if you've got
the the tattoo of the confederate flag
on your forehead and got yourself an a
an ar15 you would blend right into the
audience of that show
mate if i was if i was like born in
america
i would be like a deep south arkansas
redneck you know fox's sister kind of
guy that's
just you know that's i mean i mean
that's a that's a dream i've always
wanted quite frankly
well good luck with making that dream
happen my friend uh but listen uh thanks
for coming on the show where can people
check out and genuinely
whether people agree or disagree with
with whatever we've been talking about
you are a brilliant comic and uh your
stuff will be something that appeals to
a lot of the people who watch our show
so where can people find your stuff
online uh you can find me and thank you
for having me by the way guys i know
that we
don't agree on absolutely everything but
by god i do
love being able to like happily
and civilly disagree with with people
and not
turn it into a slanging match uh
you know enjoy the cancellation freddie
what sorry he said enjoy the
cancellation because the headline after
this will be
uh northern comedian says uh women
aren't funny or something like that
um yeah if if you want to find me
um then you can uh i uh
the best place to find my stuff at the
moment is youtube youtube.com
forward slash freddie queen comedy i
actually
uh have filmed a load of
gigs uh outdoor comedy gigs outdoors in
like
weird venues so we did one in a barn
we've done one in a field
we've done places in people's gardens we
did one on a building site that is
so [ __ ] illegal it's untrue uh we
broke every covered law but it was a
great show
and um it's it's a free series that's
going to be available
uh this month the trailers dropping on
sunday
um and it's gonna be a great way for you
to
enjoy comedy um for free
during lockdown and all you do is just
subscribe to the channel and you'll be
able to watch it
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word